[Music]
geo you're on tick tock a lot
yup did you come across this one tick
tock where this girl
was trying to convince gen z to get a
gen z tattoo
no no what's a gen z tattoo does it say
i picture it like you know the asian
style
gen like z like the writing oh yeah yeah
it looks like kanji yeah well jordan
she's 18 years old and she posted a
video on tick tock where she was
just saying like hey you know hear me
out let's get a tattoo guys
as a generation we could be united the
whole generation
you talking about gen z you talking
about the whole generation z
yes what falls under that category not
you
i know that like isn't it like 1990
something
97 of 2012. bloomberg
describes gen z as that between 1997
2012. god man i got
cars older than that [ __ ] currently it's
those
eight those between the ages of 15 and
21. that's a lie
isn't it crazy to think that the kids
born in 2000 will be able to drink next
year wow
my brother just turned 20. in september
he was born in 2000. what a old fart
he's gonna drink next year i know
he can go to vegas okay anyway back to
this so people grow up to grow up too
fast
i know right so i wasn't able to get the
original by itself
oh hold on i got the original with the
duet
which is like with when another person
does their reaction to the video
so i'm gonna be playing the original
next to the duet okay and the original
is on the right
side the right side of the screen is the
original the right one is the real one
the real one this is the reaction okay
why they look like they in the same
house though with the same walls
i don't know here we go
yeah we all got a matching tattoo as not
only a symbol of unity in our generation
but also a sign of rebellion
this is my idea what it would look like
let's make things happen
together
right everybody because that's so
[ __ ] cool
we will go down [ __ ] history for it
like we are going to be bad [ __ ]
and it's a cool [ __ ] tattoo i'm
getting it i don't care i'm about to
make my appointment
did you guys catch any of what was
happening on the left i was reading
a little bit but like not really i see
nazi symbol now is
is a thing here so it turns out that
that original
symbol that jordan wanted to have
everyone
tattoo she did not look at her oh my god
she didn't look it up
and it's actually a nazi symbol so wait
she looked it up and she was like that's
tight let's get it no
so she didn't look it up what do you
mean so she
yeah you know what's crazy though it's
kind of like bars because like
this nazi symbol is not
a z oh stupid
crazy
i didn't know they had another symbol
that's why they came up with the word
i mean what the name yeah we're not
we're not z guys
yeah what is that i thought they only
had the swastika apparently this symbol
which is why they gotta have so many
symbols make up your [ __ ] mind
so it's called wolf's angel which is
[ __ ] why does that sound tight as [ __ ]
and then they had the the iron cross and
[ __ ]
but and then the double z's and stuff
yeah
so that that double z or whatever is
part of that right
and then the sf oh the ss what kind of
the double z
that's sleeping no threes
no because they do have two z's here so
that's why i went on to
okay well maybe that's right what the
heck so
yes how many people got it at least
three people
at least three people actually do this
to their bodies
oh they have a gap that looks a little
bit different what the [ __ ] kids are
dumb
i would have got it uh-oh if she was
like we're all getting z's together i
would have been like hooray
and i would have got it and they're like
yo that's a nazi symbol
seems like an honest mistake though it
seems like it right oh no now what until
you go on her facebook
yeah she's a big ass neo-not
just kidding i thought you were so
serious you know what though
oh my god the nazis the nazis are not
original they [ __ ] stole the swastika
from the buddhist [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] so is it okay
if we steal it back and change it no
because a lot of
okay in japan or like just in a lot of
asian temples
there's swastikas everywhere right
before they were in swastikas yeah even
airports they have it they have a
not the swastika but the buddhist one
because it's flipped
and they have praying rooms and it
hasn't i remember asking i'm like oh why
is there nazi signing
all the nazis i remember seeing that too
when we went to go see the big buddha in
hong kong and i was like
what and then he was like no it's a
buddhist symbol i'm like
flipped but yeah so that's like a
[ __ ] so when it when jordan
initially posted this
she received positive responses like
teens and young adults they were just
like oh my gosh yay let's do this
let's go get it and then three people
went ahead and got the tattoo
and so after she posted it she went on
she went
to work and she did a double shift did
she even get her [ __ ] herself though
did she get the tattoo herself at least
oh that's a great question
not that i know maybe she was like i'll
throw it out there and if everyone's
down
i'll do it then i'll do it yeah and then
it comes back and it's like
oh that's a nazi symbol glad i didn't
get it
she's like gotcha yeah so then when she
got off of work
she started seeing all these like crazy
amount of response
negative response saying that it was a
nazi symbol
and she got memed hard
like really hard and she even received
death threats
god damn and then people going after
like her boyfriend
or brother i forgot you know what i
[ __ ] hate about the nazis
aside from the the obvious yeah they're
not
these not these i i wish that they had
ridiculous outfits and everything that
we can laugh at yeah instead of them
just sinking in with the
no but they had they they focused so
much on design
like the whole concept the whole concept
was basically having like they
they spent a lot of time on the occult
and design
and symbols and and how these things
make people feel right
so they made things look scary and
dangerous and all that
and like i wish they made it look
stupid as [ __ ] in a way where you're
just like
yeah you would have been as successful
as they did no
you're right because imagine like
instead of these like
crazy black cars coming out it was like
a fluffy dog car like dumb and dumber
and then the joker did it he he did it
the right way yeah
see i'm not saying they're cool i'm just
saying why the [ __ ] didn't they do it
stupid you know like some military's out
there
you see them marching and you're like oh
[ __ ] they look so stupid i'm not gonna
say which country you guys have to look
have you seen the swiss guard they look
pretty funny they do look really fun
even though they're crazy
check them out or like the or like the
dudes in london with the giant hat yo
they look ridiculous
that is crazy not as crazy as the swiss
guard really
what come out joe's gonna like it what
they look like it's like the
gucci models this looks like the new
line again they dress like that now
yes i want them to look but they're
assassins
so these guys they're like they're like
trained navy seals
but you are not scared of them at all
because they look ridiculous they look
like
[ __ ] curtains that's probably their
strategy because you're not you're not
threatened getting close
yeah you look like a curtain they could
see you from a mile away see that's
that's why i'm like why why could why
couldn't they look like a balloon and
like walking down the street or
something stupid so we can laugh at them
for the rest of our lives but then it's
scary
so now we're afraid of them because it's
like oh if you wear that uniform it's
too scary yeah with your shaved hands so
back to jordan here
she ended up posting an apology
video damn she got famous and infamous
real quick yeah so they they're
reporting that she posted
two apology videos i only have one
because she deleted everything it was
actually really hard to even find these
okay
too appreciative christian you know why
she's like oh my god my life is over
and then she deleted all the content i'm
so sorry yeah
she really did so i'm gonna show you
guys one of the videos i have here she's
like i just want this
cute tattoo i know i just wanted to
start a movement
not a nazi movement it's hard for people
man she's 18 remember
okay joe be nice she's a baby that's why
it's so funny
here we go yeah so i have seen all of
these comments
i have been writing my v's like that
since elementary
i did not think anything of it i did not
think it looked like a swastika
i did not know about the wolf angel
thing
my entire point of this was to bring my
generation together
it was about love and unity okay i
understand it needs to change and i
think people sign is a great idea
but to be getting death threats and
people texting me talking about about my
boyfriend who has nothing to do with
this
i am not charlie demilio i'm not lauren
gray okay
i don't know how to handle hate like
this
i will take everything off of the merch
store
i would just really appreciate if
everybody stopped calling me names
and hating okay i get it i'm changing it
yeah joe be nice joe yeah joe but like
okay my daddy's side is like
poor baby but the comedy side is if that
was my daughter i'd be
[ __ ] laughing would you make her get
the tattoo oh my god
if she got it already even better
because think about it right
she wanted to do something so good for
society and it went skirt
she wanted us to come to how [ __ ]
funny is that
she's like i'm gonna promote love and
unity but she actually accidentally
promoted nazism
like the backfiring it like the level of
how
opposite it is isn't that funny peak
irony
it's kind of like i want to save all of
these [ __ ] fishes right and then you
put them in the ocean and all of these
dolphins come and eat all the
[ __ ] and you're like no
i don't know i love it seems like an
honest honest mistake though can't make
honest mistakes online anymore no
exactly everything is like crucifiable
and that's it you should have known
better but also
like what's your thing what's great
about online is uh they'll forget about
it
in a month yeah but the damage it does
to someone that hasn't been seasoned
and slowly like primed into it yo if
that happened to any of us we'll just be
like
it happened again but to someone new
not to me no no don't do it to me
i don't know i think we've all been
roasted to the point where we're charred
overcooked oh [ __ ] you sound like you
have a black heart
no i'm saying that we are thick-skinned
i mean we've been in it for a long time
yeah
i remember when i got my first hate
comment and i was like ouch i got my
second one i was like
you got over it yeah the first one is
like
damn why would you want to say why why
would you want to hurt me like this and
that the second one was like
you stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you